hallo liebe zuschauer wir sind heute
wieder in berlin und zwar stehen wir
heute vor dem reichstag dem deutschen
reich zeigt wo die abgeordneten sitzen
und wir haben heute mal eine frage die
auch schon mal von euch gestellt wurde
und zwar von martin schäfer nicht allzu
langer zeit fragte er was denken die
deutschen über die eu ihr wisst
deutschland ist teil der europäischen
union
deswegen seht ihr vor dem reichstag auch
die nicht nur die deutsche sondern die
europäische flagge
wir wollen heute mal gucken was halten
die deutschen von der eu und wie sehen
sie ihre rolle in der zukunft los geht's
ich war immer ganz stark für europa und
bin auch bereit dafür alle möglichen
konsequenzen zu nehmen auch auf
finanzieller art war unheimlich
gejammert wird ob man jetzt konkret im
einzelnen wie die türkei die unbedingt
der eu beitreten will
ob das immer zum richtigen zeitpunkt und
so weiter ist dann mag man im einzelnen
darüber streiten aber ich bin jedenfalls
noch jemand der doch enorm dafür ist
noch denkst du fühlst du dich mehr also
fühlst du dich als europäer auf jeden
fall ja und denkst du dass es mehr
gemeinsamkeiten oder mehr unterschiede
gift in europa ich denke es gibt schon
unterschiede
was denken sie über die europäische
union finde ich ziemlich hinderlich was
sie sich so für gesetze und so etwas
ausdenken
ja die man verkomplizieren viele sachen
aber es war als gefühl der europäischen
idee ist grundsätzlich gut dass es die
gibt oder ist dieses nicht schlecht das
ist die würde ich sagen sind die
vorteile von der eu naja
also als gemeinschaft es ist schon gut
aber für den austausch unter den ländern
es macht auch sinn eben über europäische
angelegenheit dann entscheiden zu können
wir dann eben den ganzen kontinent
betreffen die ezb hat eine
flüchtlingskrise oder so und denken sie
dass die eu jetzt durch die letzten
diskussionen hatte um die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen und die gerechte verteilung
dass sie da auch in gefahr sein könnte
die eu ist meiner ansicht nach noch
lange nicht in gefahr aber wir sind
gerade dabei enorm rechtsrutsch in
deutschland zu machen
ein enormer widerstand dagegen und in
deutschland wird immer mehr ärger
diesbezüglich gehen und positiv gesehen
wird das beileibe schon lange nicht mehr
und was denken sie wie sich die
europäischen union vor diesem
hintergrund weiter entwickelt das ist
die frage jetzt nur die schieben alles
zu und wir sitzen jetzt damit an mit dem
problem sich das würde anderen ländern
ich würde mir wünschen dass alle das
gleiche tun wie wir dass wir das sie
also aufgeteilt werden nach irgend einen
schlüssel dass jeder das mittragen muss
deshalb sind wir ja in der europäische
union nachricht dass er sich so und die
positiven seiten so als friedensstifter
gemeinschaft ohne grenzen freizügigkeit
also ich momentan glaube ich ein problem
mit gerade mit der
flüchtlingsproblematik fühle ich mich
als deutschland sich im stich gelassen
von einigen anderen eu mitgliedstaaten
was wünschen sie sich was müsste
passieren dass die anderen sich auch mal
ein bisschen mehr verantwortlich fühlen
und nicht alles auf deutschland
abschieben
sehen sie sogar durch diese streitereien
dass gerade die europäische union
vielleicht sogar in gefahr ist doch
eigentlich nur noch wir sind doch nicht
nur noch für die wirtschaft
wirtschaftliche seite interessant für
unsere partner alles andere interessiert
jedoch glaube ich nicht so wirklich
es können viele auf deutschland abwälzen
ist meine meinung
was willst du denn passieren dass seine
dass sie sich mal ein bisschen mehr
gedanken über die flüchtlinge machen
würden und auch mal da helfend
eingreifen würden ja und wenn man ein
paar schlaue antworten will wo geht man
dann hin richtig in die universität wir
sind jetzt hier vor der
humboldt-universität in berlin wir gehen
rein und gucken was wir da so für
aussagen kriegt
nein es ist überhaupt nicht meine
doktorarbeit geschrieben
perfekt denn genau wie lange wollen sie
es denn haben kurz kurz ja gut
also ich finde die europäische union an
sich eine gute idee
allerdings so umgesetzt wird finde ich
das ein bisschen fragwürdig weil ein
also bestimmte sachen sind ja immer noch
sache der staaten der einzelnen
mitgliedstaaten
aber das geht ja irgendwo so einer
grundidee von der eu vor also wie ich
die eu interpretiere das ist ja mehr
wirklich dass es so ein einheitlicher im
moment ist es ja ein staatenverbund aber
das ist wirklich so ein staatenbund wird
das würde ich mir zumindest wünschen
ich halte die europäische union für eine
grundsätzlich sehr gute idee die
kooperation zwischen den staaten voran
bringt und dazu führt dass
trotz
schluss die kooperation zwischen den
staaten fördert und mit sicherheit dazu
geführt hat dass sich sehr viele
erleichterungen ergeben haben in europa
ich glaube jetzt gerade hat die
europäische union vor allem das problem
dass starten an dem punkt sind an dem
sie auf viele ihre befugnisse verzichten
müssen damit das projekt weitergeht und
das sind sie derzeit nicht bereit zu tun
und man wird sehen wie es weitergeht was
denkst du über die europäische union
ich finde es eigentlich von der dh etwas
toll ist halt dass der der austausch der
europäischen länder miteinander was halt
kulturelle und wirtschaftliche vorteile
mit sich bringt und das ist gerade mit
der krise krise ist sage ich ist es halt
ein problem aber natürlich ist es halt
dann die feuerprobe für die eu
denn ich würde mal sagen die meisten die
meisten aktionen kommt gestärkt aus
einer krise raus oder halt anders oder
neu heraus was denken sie denn riesch
ich glaube wir werden noch ein paar
jahre weiter mehren ohne dass es große
fortschritte geben wird
und dann gibt es sehen sie die eu
realistisch in gefahr sogar dadurch das
glaube ich nicht
ich glaube nicht dass das projekt
einfach so gegeben wird
das wird immer so als schreckensszenario
an die wand gemalt aber ich glaube also
ich glaube das schlimmste was passieren
könnte wäre das ist ein völlig hohles
bündnis wird so ein bisschen wie der
senat in star wars ja liebe zuschauer
das war's in dieser woche mit easy
german diese woche hatten würde ein
thema das ein bisschen mehr politisch
ist diesmal speziell für martin schuh
die frage die duh gestellt hast wenn ja
auch meine frage habt schreibt sie uns
unbedingt in die kommentare
wo wir möchten auch gerne von euch
wissen was haltet ihr von politischen
themen möchte neben mehr politische
themen oder sagt ihr macht mal lieber
was aus dem alltag
wir freuen uns auf eure meinung und
sagen tschüss und bis zur nächsten woche
in der zukunft in zukunft